a vast GB babies it's me Kevin Smith
Jason have you ever wanted to get lost
on the high seas with Jay and Silent Bob
well now you're gonna have your chance
go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew what
are you waiting for man get lost at sea
with Jay and Silent bone let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
out there in Internet land uh my name is
Mark Bernard welcome to uh a random
somewhat impromptu episode of black man
beyond uh hi oh hey ho it's just me it's
just me here you guys
um you know Kevin is off and Kevin
landia doing Kevin things as one does
um uh I'm I'm going to assume that many
of you have have seen uh the People
magazine uh story about Kev and his uh
his journey towards mental health if you
haven't seen it I mean you absolutely
should it's uh it is a incredibly
wonderful incredibly helpful incredibly
sage and insightful
um Diary of his journey and explaining
you know how he feels how he felt what
his process is and you know where he
thinks he is and where he thinks he's
going um if you haven't you should it's
beautiful
um and I'm so proud of Kevin for doing
that and for eight getting the help that
he thought he needed and then be talking
about it to other people who may or may
not
um be in touch with their own sense of
mental health
um again you should go do that
um that is the extent of the plugging of
Kevin things that I will do and then you
saw the view Askew thing the cruiser
skew you should come we're gonna have a
blast my first cruise I've been on a
cruise before so what better way to do
it than surrounded by you know a
thousand people who
um
are there because they want to see us
that seems fun right as opposed to a
bunch of strangers it's a bunch of
strangers with like-minded interests
that aren't just drinking
although that could be like my ninjas as
well but hey hey everybody I hope you're
well
um I hope what what is this this is the
end of April I was about to say I hope
your Summer's been going great it's not
summer yet I know that it feels like it
but it is
um it is however a weird season of flux
um specifically for me specifically for
uh anybody that you know who writes
things in Hollywood The Writer's Guild
of America in both the East and the West
Coast contingents are uh the contract
that we have with the uh the motion
picture uh television producing Alliance
or whatever the amptp is the the uh the
acronym
um it expires every three years uh on
May 1st and we we renegotiate our deal
with the studios
which basically means like here's how
much money we get for writing an observe
TV here's how much money we get
um in residuals for writing set episode
of TV
um here's what we uh and by what we get
I mean the Medicals like there's a floor
that they can't pay you less than you
can always negotiate for more there but
if the the bottom that's the important
part
um in trying to keep uh people from
getting screwed more than they want to
be screwed
and and more importantly it keeps
writing for television a career that's
sustainable
um it had always been a pretty decent
job
um especially in the in the heady days
of the 80s and 90s and 2000s when there
was only Network TV
um or only cable TV and they could run
ads during each of those programs and
the ads brought to the revenue
and so then the wonders of syndication
where you made your 100 episodes of The
X-Files and then you could sell it to
syndication and that was another Revenue
stream for the studios and then the
writer's Guild has over the years
um fought to make sure that the writers
who created that stuff get to take part
in the success of that stuff
um the residual structure is what they
call it
um and so every three years we we have
to sit down with the studios and fight a
little bit to get what we think is is a
fair uh slice of that pie
um the last time the writer's Guild went
on strike which was
2007-2008 I believe
um it was mostly over the Internet it
was mostly over the the beginning of
streaming
um at that point the studio said well
stream you just you know where we're
putting his marketing stuff is where
we're putting like you know whatever
free for Content that we created just to
help sell the show we're not going to
put episodes Up We're not gonna put a
guy we would never put a whole series up
um it's just as promotional and then you
know with living where we live living
when we live we know how that went and
so it was very important to fight for
you know jurisdiction over the Internet
because somebody at the time saw down
the road not that far and said well if
you can do this with marketing stuff how
long until you put this online
which they did
and so now we are we are uh we are
facing a television landscape that's
different than it ever been
um streaming the most convenient way
that any of us watch television
um functionally broke television as we
know in that
um instead of being able to make money
by selling ads instead of being able to
to make money by selling it to
syndication the streamers especially the
ones who produce original content at
this point that's all of them
um can really only make money
um by subscriptions and
that's not that much money
um not in the way that it used to be
um don't get me wrong Netflix is doing
fine Netflix has you know 200 million
some some odd subscribers and that means
that every month all of those 200
million people are getting hit for
between you know 10 15 sometimes 20
bucks a month
that's a lot of money
so
um the the studios in present are saying
that the pandemic and streaming have
affected their income streams or
whatever and we don't want to cut
anybody in for anymore because we're
struggling out there despite again being
able to charge people you know
two billion dollars a month
um
in a in gross revenue so nevertheless
that is what the strike if there's a
strike is going to be about it's going
to be about making sure that that
writers like me and like my friends and
like my colleagues and like the 11 000
of us that are out there working in
Hollywood
um can can can have a career
um and can can make enough money and
listen I'm not going to tell you what
the the dollar figures are because it's
it is already ridiculous and I know that
it's a king's Ransom except that we're
living if you're living in Los Angeles
you're living in a place where it costs
a king's Ransom to live
um so functionally it is not that much
money
um I don't know where you live but I'm
pretty sure that wherever that is it's
not going to cost you 1.5 million
dollars for a three-bedroom house that
does not have a helipad that does not
have a boat launch and does not have a
trans-dimensional portal it is just a
house
um that's what real estate costs are
everything costs more out here
um but it's a company town and so the
company town has to pay Company wages
um but functionally that's what it is it
is trying to carve for ourselves a piece
of the pie that makes doing this work
and living where we live
um sustainable and tenable
um and it'd be great to be rich but not
asking for Rich asking for Fairly
compensated is where we are
um so our contract uh expires at
midnight on uh May the 1st
we'll see what happens there's there's
aggressive negotiations going on right
now between the studios and the writer's
Guild negotiating committee
um
whatever you're hearing about the strike
and you know if you're the kind of
person who reads you know the the
entertainment
um blogs and websites and the trade
magazines you know they will all say one
thing or another they're most of his
speculation if not all of it is
speculation because nobody's talking
um at least to the public I hope they're
talking to each other because that would
be great
um but uh it's it is a it is a fraught
time for folks like me who are staring
down the barrel of months
of Unemployment uh you know the last
strike went for 100 days and that is a
long time to not be making money
especially in a place that's expensive
as Los Angeles
but it's it's a fight that needs
fighting it's a fight that that you know
the writer's Guild is always
um I'm not going to say down for because
nobody wants a strike but they're they
are to the best of my knowledge the only
Guild or Union in Hollywood that's ever
struck
um because we have a pretty solidified
um membership who all believe in what we
do and the value of what we do and so
we'll stand for it and we'll fight for
it
um the fight's different every time the
internet you know pension Health Care
um you know reproductive care is part of
healthcare all of those you know sort of
things that you'd think you wouldn't
have to fight for against you know
billion dollar companies
um I think we're asking for two pennies
in the dollar
which doesn't seem a lot for the people
who make up all of the stuff that you
watch on TV and in movies
um so yeah that's what's happening at
least in my world I I I am lucky in that
I do get to write other things that are
not
um just movies or TV
um I do get to work on video games which
it's not covered by The Writer's Guild
so I can work on it I get to write comic
books which not covered by The Writer's
Guild so I can work on it
um and I can have some Revenue coming in
for however long this strike will last
um but it's it is nowhere near ideal
nobody wants it
um but that's what makes it hard and the
hard things are often worth doing
so
um that is that is I suppose what passes
for personal news other than like hey
you know we're still not there touring
Splinter we were at the Overlook Film
Festival uh last month we've got another
Film Festival coming up in in June that
I can't quite say which one it is yet
I'm supposed to wait for them to
announce
um we get plans to bring it to Comic-Con
um not as part of the film festival but
just as we'll have a panel we'll show
the short we'll talk about it
um on Shanghai
start not going to say that anymore I
will uh I will Wrangle as many members
of the cast and crew as as I can to come
down to San Diego for at least a day and
uh and talk about and talk about our
little movie
um
oh yeah that's uh
that's it that's it that's all I got
we're going to talk about a little bit
of news Cinema Khan is currently going
on
um I think it's starting to wrap up but
uh we'll talk about the things that got
announced and things that got first
looks of
um sorry about a couple of trailers that
came out of there we're gonna talk about
the Mandalorian
season finale
um and then we're going to talk about
the Star Trek Picard series finale
um which I have all of the feelings
about
um and I think uh because Banff man is a
little under the weather
um dilfman is standing by on Deck to
talk to uh to Picard it's a Picard with
me
um
but yeah I think
you know like this is going to be a
chill this is gonna be a chill afternoon
you guys what do you think or whatever
time it is whatever you happen to be
um we have uh turned off the Super Chat
because
yeah we know what happened last time
so yeah not gonna do that um I'm not
looking at the chat because I'd rather
just talk to you hi everybody how are
you how's your day going it's all right
excellent so how do you love me
um but before we get into anything else
before we get into the meat of the the
Navy and the gritty
um I do haven't had to read
um
and it's this is a weird one and I'll
tell you why because it is both
incredibly timely and I'm not entirely
sure right for this audience
um but if you are a sports ball fan
person
um specifically the football sports fan
person specifically American football
sports fan person then you'll know that
today is the first day of the NFL draft
which is when none of the teams get to
choose what players are going to play
for them so thankfully uh the good Folks
at manscape have an NFL draft theme ad
so let's just get into it I'm gonna read
it well you know we're not gonna talk
about it because it'll say anything to
say and then we're going to get on with
the rest of our show okay you guys
um and they say Q uh NFL draft sound if
possible I don't know what that sound is
um
I'm assuming it's like some horns
maybe I don't know some John teshi
um whatever
um hey kids the NFL draft is here and
the most exciting prospect is the
prospect of being perfectly groomed Head
To Toe with our friends at manscape
manscape has long head Elite downfield
play with a longhorn 4.0 but in 20 2023
they have the rookie sensation beard
hedger to ensure the face of your
franchise is a pretty one this one-two
punch of Men's Grooming is the best
acquisition for any home GM so go to
manscape.com and save some salary cap
with our code Fatman for 20 off plus
free shipping again remember 20 off free
shipping with the code Fatman at
manscape.com
um this year manscape can help you make
the sexy pick without forgetting about
your big uglies up front that's right
the beard hedger and lawnmower 4.0 are
franchise changing combo that will have
you looking at your roster with pride
everyone who saw the Super Bowl
hopefully some of you at the very least
know where the Super Bowl is uh knows
what can happen with poorly managed
grass that type of ball playing field
quality would never happen with the
lawnmower 4.0 this Elite electric
trimmer is a lock for first round Talent
just look at its explosive Talent with
RPM all that power with all that power
the lawnmower is still the most middle
what Nimble on the field nipple
okay on the field with its skin safe
technology that reduced your Nicks and
snags while making all the right cuts on
hair in the season of trimming the
roster manscape will make sure you're
cutting all the right players and not
any important pieces to your D defense
date nice
now now you've done the dirty work now
it's time to make sure you look good out
there with a beard hedger and it's 20
positions of precision this powerful
cordless trimmer helps you customize
your look with a rotary wheel that has
20 lengths while only using one guard
in football having a Depot line might be
a good thing but in the bathroom more
than one guard is just a mess
plus it's tough titanium blades and
single stroke efficiency seeing that
there should be a joke with single
stroke efficiency but uh never mind can
have you going can have you go from a
bushy matte
what
I'm going to skip that that's like we
are deep inside football coach talk
um whatever's Sean mcvehunts anyway if
you haven't upgraded your grooming tools
already head to manscape.com for a
champion worth roster reset
so get 20 off and free shipping with the
code Fatman at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code Fatman at checkout go
from Mr Irrelevant to a first round pick
with manscape and we thank the good
Folks at manscape for sponsoring this
episode of oh it's Batman 20. Batman 20
and I tell you I'm not doing the read
again but it's femin 20. not just fat
man fat man 20. otherwise
um you're just gonna get manscape stuff
for an extra 20 and no free shipping
let's use a cup fat man 20.
um thank you to the good folks of at
manscape for supporting continually
supporting this podcast and our Daffy
ass advertise thank you guys
[Music]
everybody thanks
um so uh let's talk
mando
did you guys watch the mando I mean I'm
sure you did it's
a couple weeks old by now
um I will say that the Mandalorian
season finale was a pretty strong
episode
um maybe the best episode of a season
that I didn't find overwhelmingly
um
I'm not gonna say enjoyable but just
substantive
um I I and we spoke about it we spoke we
spoke about it a couple of times here on
the podcast that it felt a bit revelous
it felt a bit directionless it felt a
bit you know we're just gonna go and do
this story whether it adds up to
anything or not we're just gonna go
check in with these characters whether
they continue the the threat or not
um you know and so to finally get to
engage with uh with Darth jetpack and
off Gideon
um you know is great like I will happily
take Giancarlo Esposito anytime I can in
my science fiction and or fantasy
um and so when he's there which he is
very heavily in the final episode
um and he's great he's always great
um I kind of wish he was the bad guy for
the season
um so that there was actually some
threat and some pressure
placed on din Jaron and uh and we baby
grogu who's you know 200 years old or
whatever I still can't talk
um
and so like by the time you get to the
end of it it's like oh yeah no this was
fun like I dug it it's a good episode
there's a lot of action the action's
great
um you know it does sort of advance to
some story I guess in that you know the
mandalorians have Mandalore back and
and you know then John adopts grogu is
his I guess you know team Ward it's you
know fight crime together
um you know didn't grow goo and uh
didn't German or hang it out in the
house by the frontier and floating frogs
and sipping Seth Barilla and waiting for
adventure to cross their their front
door
um and that's you know great it's a nice
tidy bow I I just my my quibble has
always been I'm not sure why we needed
any of the other episodes to get us here
um because it didn't seem like a
culmination as much as it seemed like a
good episode and that's fine I suppose
um but that's a that's a long time to be
you know
it's a long road to walk especially if
we did need to walk that road at all
um it didn't feel like again like a
culmination it just felt like an episode
um
but you know and hey I'm always here for
Katie Sackhoff as as Boca 10 I'm always
here for for
um you know Giancarlo Esposito is Mount
Gideon I'm always here for whomever is
in the Mandalorian costume at any given
time and you know Pedro Pascal's voice
chiming in from wherever he is in the
world
um
I just yeah I I I continue to kind of
want more
um from this show
um as I've sort of felt from the
beginning and it's and the show's giving
you a lot
but
you know
it's giving you a lot of things I just
know if it's quite giving you enough
things because I was not oh hey oh hi
Mark
hey Will welkins what's up um I just
wanna I hope you don't mind my
interjecting I just wanted to ask a
question as a writer okay
um because I I did a re-watch of Mando
one and two seasons before three and the
one thing that I got out of it is that
you know it actually still follows the
same pattern of slow sluggishness and
then a fast ramp up at the end but as a
writer how did you feel about the build
up uh of the dark saber if you will only
to spoilers have it kind of crushed at
the end and become a non-thing
I mean the darksaber was so weird
because you know it it's another it's
another element of Canon that I don't
have an emotional attachment to because
again I gotta mentioned it before I
didn't watch all of Clone Wars I didn't
watch any of rebels
um so so the whole Mandalorian War and
the Boca 10 and the the offshoots and
the the you know the the weird Church
state of the Mandalorian society and and
all of that you know I like I understood
it but it didn't mean anything to me and
you know there's there's a there's a bit
and I want to say like episode seven or
eight of this season of Mandalorian
where like
you know uh mando
is explaining that like well here's what
happened
um I was kidnapped by a creature and I
lost the dark side of that creature and
then Boca 10 killed that creature and so
that she by rights has the dark saber
it's like bro you could have said that
anything you could just give it her the
sword
you know why does it have to be this
weird like they they draw this out like
I have to without the sword I can't
leave my people you can have it you
earned it but he saves it for the most
dramatic moment you know like you knew
this for four episodes man like and so
it it was never clear to me what
how important it was it was never clear
to me really how functional it was
because it was as functional I suppose
as it needed to be in any given episode
especially since then John couldn't
really use it very well
you know so like as a totem it kind of
didn't do the thing I needed it to do
and then for somebody to just like oh I
just broke it with my hand
and you're like but what what well I
mean I I did I did pick up because I'm
I'm very attuned to audio and so I did
pick up that one of the things that moth
Gideon had like there was some I don't
want to say cybernetic help there but
his armor definitely had some servos and
gears and to provide a little more
strength yeah it was very like Iron Man
yeah whereas their other mandalorians
didn't feel particularly Iron Man they
just feel like we got jet packs that's
cool right we're just Knights knights in
in white jet packs
um whereas yeah Gideon was I'm full on
Iron Man I'm I'm the Iron Monger I'm
just crushing things
um and so like I get it but it just it
all feels very anticlimactic
it all feels very like all right we're
gonna have this final battle where all
these mandalorians are flying around in
the arrogance all these you know clone
troopers or whatever and
I guess like none of that is the story
that I'm emotionally invested in I'm
invested in
and the more you take me away from that
story the less I care about what happens
um and so like yeah I mean darksaber
sure I guess it's cool until it isn't I
guess it's cool until you just get rid
of it for reasons why I don't know
you know yeah
there's a lot of just nah I guess like
why did grogu need uh a weird artificial
suit to walk around in when he had a
perfectly good floating thing that also
did the job easier and better because he
can't grab people's arms and tell them
no with that and also how does he do all
that articulating with just two
joysticks and some buttons man yeah like
I guess to give Mando a hand like oh I
lifted you off the ground yes yes yes
okay I suppose like just let the kid
talk
some language well so he uses the force
he could lift easily lift you know
Amanda off the ground with the force
so
I don't know I don't know like just
threads that didn't seem to go anywhere
like we went through the whole Dr
Pershing episode I guess to meet to to
re-engage with that you know woman who
was MAF Gideon spy yeah the
communications officer Elaine something
right and so and she seems to exist
solely to tell nav Gideon uh the
mandalorians are back on Mandalore he's
like no that's bad I'll deal with it
like could have been an email like we
definitely didn't need
an episode a complete episode devoted to
this woman simply so that she can drop
some plot in the finale
um I think and if you don't mind me
sharing my opinion
um my whole problem with the third
season of Mando don't get me wrong I
still will take any Star Wars I can get
my only problem with it is that I feel
like with whatever
machinations are going on behind the
scenes in the business side of things
the whole season just feels like a setup
season for something else it's for all
the other story lines they're telling so
they can give us little teases so they
can get one character to be able to say
thrawn for example you know
that's just mine too I mean it's I they
keep trying to make thrawn happen and
again never once Rebels doesn't mean
anything to me you know that's that's
the that's the pitfall that's the Trap
of continuity right like
if it doesn't mean anything to you it's
just words and you can't hang emotion on
words to a stranger you know like that's
dealing with Legacy Media that's that's
the biggest trap of it I said oh we're
just gonna mention this and this is
gonna be cool oh I'm just gonna show
this and this will be cool but if it
doesn't mean anything if you haven't in
the front story established why I should
care then it's just you know it's just
sort of deep nerd bait which you know I
don't always respond to
um
to a certain degree rarely do I respond
to because it's not drama
you know you're not you're not giving me
conflict it's just do you remember this
remember this and if you don't then it's
just kind of hollow
um you know I and I and I remember
having my problems with season one of
Mandalorian
but what I remember liking the most
about it was it required no previous
knowledge of Star Wars like you could
just like we're rolling with this this
guy's gonna do some cool stuff he found
this baby baby's cute as hell you know
we're gonna go from planet to planet
we're gonna discover some stuff we're
gonna learn the lesson and then we're
gonna move on and then the more we
started to engage with you know the old
Canon with Clone Wars with the prequels
you know the more we started to get kind
of deep in those weeds it just got less
emotional for me like you know I'm
always here for Rosario Dawson but
Ahsoka Tano doesn't really mean that
much to me you know but if you if you
then just reintroduce that character in
a cool way in a Jedi who walked away
from them from the from the Faith from
the path like okay that's interesting
let's talk about that but it never
really does because you know she's in
there for an episode episode and a half
and then she sort of dances out you know
like Luke Skywalker oh that's cool
I guess because Luke's doing cool stuff
like that's neat but we also know what
happens there so
we kind of know where he's gonna go and
then the next time we see him like he's
just like the most boring teacher of a
very new school
you know in a completely different show
you know and and time is weird in this
show and then I remember hearing you
know I think we talked about the Favreau
said that like yeah it's been it was two
years or something between when Luke
dropped when when when Mando dropped off
girl who was Luke and when they reunited
okay I like 13 years I like that you say
reunited when realistically speaking it
was like Luke just let the auto ship
drop the kid off after he got rejected
yeah you know it's over
um so it's just it's the emotional
engagement that I have with the show
um I struggle with
to your point and I agree with you I'm
always here for a little bit of Star
Wars
um but I just I wish it came to me with
the same amount of rigor that I'm coming
to get mm-hmm and so far it it hasn't
you know with exceptions like there have
been great episodes of Mandalorian there
have been great scenes of Mandalorian
um you know just as there were great
episodes of of uh of Kenobi just as all
of Andorra was great right
which is possible and that's what makes
I think in a way what we got with with
uh the third season here of Mandalorian
it's practically coming off of the heels
of an amazing story that was told in the
first season of Andor you know where
we've seen great compelling dramatic
Star Wars can be done
yeah it it it's hard to exist in the
shadow of that particular show when
you're off trying to make your own Star
Wars and I get it you know and and
watching you know the the Dr Pershing
episode try to be its version of Andor
um
degrees of success like I at least dug
it for the for the uh for the attempt at
it I don't think it got there but like
once you see what Star Wars can do it's
hard to just sort of accept sometimes
what Star Wars is
uh right now I just imagined that that
bam fan JC is somewhere going sensing a
deep disturbance in the sports force and
wanting to claw this show back yeah yeah
it's like you picked a wig that I'm sick
to talk about Mando I'm like well hey
man don't get sick
right it's on you and your immune system
it's not a conversation I need to be a
part of
um you know but I'm I'm curious about
the Ahsoka show you know because again
always here for Rosario
um I thought that first trailer we
talked about it the trailer that they
dropped at Celebration looked great you
know I don't know who thrawn is
really but I'm hoping that the show will
tell me why I should be afraid of him or
excited to see him or whatever like
you know assuming these things are or
understood is is the sort of classic
mistake
of Legacy Media and just because you
recognize a thing doesn't mean that it's
doing its job
Nostalgia is hell of a drug unless you
don't have any Nostalgia for it and then
it's just not that didn't do anything
it's the weird dank weed that you smoked
that didn't get you high and you're like
well you didn't do the thing I always
promised you would do
so what's the point
um so yeah that was that was my Mando
that was my Mando take
um I like this episode but I didn't
particularly like this season
um
which you know again everybody's mileage
may vary you might have loved it and I'm
glad you did I hope you did
um because this world is just shitty
enough that if we can find the things
that we like and rally around them all
the better
um just didn't quite work for me
fair enough you know what did
work for me though amen I know where
you're going
um season three of Picard
um
now it's interesting to talk about
season three of bakar the series finale
and all this season entirely in the same
brace is talking about Star Wars because
both of these things are operating from
a place of nostalgia I mean Star Wars is
almost entirely powered by by nostalgia
um and as was the third season of Picard
like it was let's get the band back
together let's get everybody who was
ever on the bridge of the Starship
Enterprise and the Next Generation back
again for One Last Ride
um
and the sort of measured way that this
season assembled that crew once again
the surprising pass that it took with
some of those characters the the you
know and the stuff that I didn't even
think possible but like oh you gotta
roll laryn back
like and you gave her a fantastic
episode and you know we're we're gonna
spoil some here guys it's been it's
been a week
um so we're not gonna deep spoil but
we're gonna mention some things that
happen so if you want to watch Picard I
hope you did if you didn't maybe just
kind of go off screen for a while
um but to bring her back and have her
you know render that service that she
renders to to Jean-Luc Picard and the
crew of the Titan
um is wonderful you know and it's it's
it it Harkens back to a relationship
that even the Next Generation never got
to really deepen in the way that I think
and wanted to
um you know the jacket Crusher stuff I
think wore a little thin for me
um
just because you know like
hiding that ball like what is Jack
Crusher why does everybody care
um by the time you got the answer to
that it wasn't that fulfilling
then he was just kind of like you know a
plot ball that just got bounced around a
lot
but I mean by the time you get to the
the second to last episode and they're
back on the Enterprise D you
don't care you know
you know like listen I I worked on
season two
of the card which you know has its
merits but it's definitely not season
three and so I know some of the guys
over there and I literally texted Terry
metallis the showrunner I was like dude
I'm sitting here in my office crying
because they're on the
Enterprise D again and they're all there
you know it's like not that I I never
had a dream that it would happen like
who knows as a fan you're like well
those days are done or to like get and
get it back on that break so they
rebuilt that bridge like
it was it was weaponized Nostalgia and
it completely it was I'm sorry it was
perfectly deployed as well because it's
the one thing I don't think anyone
conceived would be possible so when it
happened I you know I can't I'm not like
these kids I can't stay up and watch
these shows when they drop at midnight
but I was I was sitting in my family
room at 5 30 in the morning and that was
happening and I just suddenly I was just
glued like a little kid watching TV
again but crying like an old man
remembering what it was like to be that
kid yeah you know it just it it hit me
in exactly the right place at exactly
the right time
um you know the the sacrifice of Captain
Shaw who I thought was a fantastic
character and I'm sad that he's gone
quite sad because you know who knows if
they ever make a Star Trek Legacy show I
don't know if that's a thing that's
going to happen the internet seems to
want it desperately
um you know I would have liked to have
seen Shaw in that show
um because I mean
geez like Todd stashworth is a fantastic
actor that's a terrific character give
me give me more of that all of that
which which I would have loved to have
seen more of that character because the
the things that we got out of him first
of all like you said a great actor but
some of the elements he brought being an
engineer on during wolf 359 and how he
feels about Picard being in the same
room with him in some sense is you know
that was just way powerful storytelling
that I just it smacked me upside the
head
yeah you know I mean there's there's and
there was that moment I think it might
be the same episode or maybe it's a
previous episode
what Jack is talking about you know you
you discover the time that Jack found
his father for the first time you know
it's a pub where it was you know some
fleet holiday and a bunch of cadets were
there and John Picard is eating his fish
and chips and they start asking him
about things and he's telling the story
as an admiral talking about how
important that you know Starfleet is to
him and how your crew is your family and
then you know crash that Crusher looks
up and it's like well you know what
about family like do you ever have any
regrets do you ever wish that you know
things had gone different you ever wish
that you had children you know and he's
like Starfleet is my family you know and
just watching that break the heart of a
young man who thought he was going to
connect with his dad
you know who just smacked them down
without even realizing how hard the blow
was you know like that's
it was all such very deaf storytelling
it very much knew
um where it was going
um it was it was careful with the Easter
eggs but they were there and they were
plenty and you know I'm sure that there
were dreams that they had of getting you
know Kate Mulgrew back that there were
dreams they had of getting you know
other various armors I mean getting
Cisco back getting you know not a
visitor back to play Kira like I'm sure
there's but and once you build the
Enterprise D Bridge there's put so much
money left in the bank to secure you
know guest stars but like you know
having you know Admiral Shelby
um as the leader of the you know
whatever whatever the name of that day
was you know I want to say Patriots Day
but I know that that's not what it is no
I and I should really remember myself
because they said it 45 million days it
were times yeah it wasn't Founder's Day
it was something else
no
um but uh that's how relevant it was
who cares
um but you know Shelby who was in you
know Best of Both Worlds Parts one and
two as the sort of young upstart
underneath Riker who was trying to
assert his position on the Enterprise
and to see her back 30 years later as an
admiral after all you know all that
stuff was great but it's
it's just watching that crew you know
watching that gang finally back together
again on the bridge finally you know
skulking through a board Cube to like
you know save a Picard you know like all
that stuff is just fun I mean my one my
one the one thing that I was hoping
would happen I understand why I didn't
for all of the reasons
but I was hoping that not everybody
would make it out of that
you know I was kind of I was I was
hoping for a bit more Wrath of Khan than
Voyage Home you know where there was a
cost and there was a sacrifice and
somebody had to make a choice and it was
the hardest choice
um
you know and I I I could tell you who I
think I'd like that liked to have had
that person be
um
but and I understand why because it does
it casts everything in a different light
if once you go around that poker table
at the end of the show
there's an empty seat there but I still
like I think that's moving to me I think
that that's that's what it costs to do
this kind of heroism that's what it
costs to to be you know a member of
Starfleet you know a member of the
Enterprise crew you'd have to be willing
to make the hard call
um and you know roll the hard six
uh just do it from a different spaceship
show
um speaking of a different spaceship
um I thought it was interesting I I
don't think it was intentional but there
really seemed to be some parallels
between this episode and some of the
things we've gotten from Star Wars you
know like a particular ship flying in
through another particular ship in order
to destroy the thing at the center
yeah you know there's definitely some
Jedi at the very Talent of that
um you know and I think that that those
two those two universes especially in
the last 15 years or so have kind of
cross-pollinated a little bit you know
especially Star Wars seeping into Star
Trek because I think that's very much
what JJ was trying to do with his Star
Trek was like the second Star Wars let's
make it fun
you know it's not going to be intensely
cerebral we're just going to like hold
on it's going to be a bumpy ride you
guys you know and to get to see and they
couldn't do that 90s on Star Trek
because the technology is not there to
have the Enterprise doing donuts
and in space
we got a sad model and we're just
shooting around you guys we even got
some fast and furious in this one man
Liz's life won parsec at a time
um but I I I was I was incredibly
satisfied
um by the end of this finale it uh it
checked all the boxes you wanted to
check it was exciting it was Star Trek
it was you know Space Battles you were
on Enterprise with these people and you
know getting to see Wharf be a badass
who has to knock on the bridge getting
to see Jordy you know as a father who's
you know incredibly painstakingly you
know careful with his things to the
point where like when his kids go sort
of AWOL like he's a broken man
um you know the Riker Troy relationship
and how that's sort of metastasized over
the years and the death of his son and
the of how that can Fray a marriage
um to say the least
um you know then just a card like how
can you be useful
you know at at an advanced stage how do
you how are you relevant
um when you are this person how can you
use your worst days to inform your best
days
um I think all that was really powerful
I think it was all incredibly well
handled and you know and and the show of
it all like how do you
how do you change what you know to be
true
with the presence of new information
you know when do you when do you learn
how to trust your gut when the book is
the thing you've been going by your
entire life like all of that stuff is
great you know and being able to kind of
Marshal it and use it and and
and inform it
the past and the present like I thought
it's just a fantastic job
um and I know we've we've kind of talked
about a lot of the elements but you know
I'm sure as a writer well first of all I
I just have to ask and if you can't talk
about it because it's too inside
baseball but when you when you came on
during season two were you did they make
you aware of the road map going in what
would be season three
um there were some very early
discussions about you know and not in
any way we never talked about the next
gen cast coming back that was never part
of it I think that that was
that was uh that was decided
um much later in the in the go gotcha
but I remember we were just having
conversations about like what is the the
last best destiny
for Jean-Luc Picard like where should he
end his story you know should it be
surrounded by friends should he die you
know in the Chateau in the vineyard you
know surrounded by his crew like
you know maybe he's got a positronic
body should he just be on the bridge of
a Starship for eternity is he the last
Captain is he just this this eternal
Sentinel of the Federation who you know
if you ever need me I'll be there just
send up a flare and I'll come running
you know like all of those things were
discussed early on and nothing had ever
been settled on and
clearly you know once they decided to
bring back the next gen cast that it
becomes a very different conversation
now what is all of their Fates together
um
you know but I think the the engaging
with John Lee Picard's past
um was was attractive you know you know
the Borg is always attractive you know I
think you know Season Two was very much
about cue and you know cue in the Borg
are the two great inventions of of the
Next Generation
Um
we had never discussed
um changelings you know and I just loved
how much DS9 was in this episode this
season you know how much of the the the
threats and the lessons and and the
characters of these are it's not I mean
I wish again wish we got to see Cisco I
wish we've gotten see O'Brien I wish
we'd gotten to see
you know a Trill that would have been
great
um you know I mean Wharf was on DS9 so
that's not insignificant either but
um you know endings are are a very
delicate thing I mean just as Beginnings
are and and to come up with the way to
satisfactorily end those stories and
find those places
um
I just think it's a masterful I've never
seen a show
um level up
the way this show did oh yeah you know
seasons one and two are whatever
um but I've never seen a show just go
from like okay to All-Star
in the span of one season but does that
all come from the writing because I know
not only did it seem that they had a
good story you know granted the Jack
Crusher stuff it was the pardon the term
but in shows we tend to get what I call
a long uncomfortable hand job and some
plot elements and that was that for me
but also not only the story but the
writing was really good like some of the
things they interwove comedy in a way I
don't think we really saw in next gen
into this one right down to Like the
Wolf saying and I'll make it a threesome
and then Riker's just instantly chiming
in do you even hear yourself
but yeah the story was great my whole
point is I thought the writing was great
but as a writer you know is it something
you came away from going wow they really
nailed it oh yeah yeah I mean it it you
know to harmonize with my my opening
speech about the the writers and the
potential strike
it always begins in the page you know it
always begins on like all right what
story should we tell and if you have the
right crew of people and if you have the
right support from the people but the
money
um you know be at the network in the
studio then like you're given license to
kind of dream that way and and once it
becomes clear so guys we want to bring
the next gen cash back it's like all
right well that's going to cost us but
we think it's willing it's worth doing
because here's the story that makes it
worth doing you know we gotta rebuild
the bridge of the Enterprise all right
well that's expensive but here's why
it's worth doing
it must it must have been worth doing
because as I heard they only had two
shooting days on that set that was it
yeah you know and so
it's a it's a Herculean effort to make a
show that good
um especially from the bones of the show
that it had been
um you know and there is there is
something liberating about knowing that
it's the final season right let's just
leave it on put it on the field to
borrow a sports metaphor I'll leave
nothing in the tank because we don't
it's a one-way trip guys we don't have
to get back home we don't have to start
this again next year we don't have to
back to one it's just this is the end of
the story so what's the best version
this week and do and I was incredibly
impressed that this was indeed the best
version that I think anybody could have
done I mean yeah I'd have killed in
person
but that's just me and I'm a little
bloodthirsty
are you are you not you just absolutely
won't say who it was because
after the show oh by the way on Frontier
day the whole chat told his Frontier day
Frontier day
um I would have killed Picard oh I think
I think I think him sacrificing himself
for his son for his crew you know when
he plugs himself back into the board you
know I think like he's the virus that
gets rid of the Borg and but he can
disengage and he's got to stain he's
gotta blow it up from the inside and
and that's the price that gets paid to
save everybody else
um and at the end of one's Road like
you know he doesn't need a heroic you
know farewell but like
I am as I always was the kind of person
I'm going to make hard decisions
um for the safety of my crew and this is
the biggest one and it's the last one
and you know
that that's just me
um because I do I do like a little
bitter with my sweet and that finale is
very very sweet
um especially the last Act of that show
and so just the like yeah we're all a
little bit Hollow we're all a little bit
empty from this but
he he chose this this was his choice
you know he chose to stare down his own
you know weaknesses he chose to stare
down the worst moment of his life when
he gave you know it's rendered to the
Borg and lost everything that he was and
do it again but now for the right reason
um you know like I think there's
something really poetic and tragic in
that
um I think anybody else you know killing
would have been you know Boromir without
dying like yeah we feel something but
like it doesn't it doesn't feel as
crucial to the story if like oh man we
killed data again okay all right you
know we killed Wharf
it was not a good day to die because
it's not his story
um you know they they tried to prep us
for Riker and or you know uh Deanna
dying but like they were always covered
in plot armor they were never gonna buy
it
um so I also I also knew they were never
gonna buy it because the episode where
we know they're on the other ship
there's one character you do not see
that entire episode
I'm just saying go back and re-watch
y'all
um but no I I'm very much dug it I very
much was impressed by it
um and I hope they make more Star Trek
like this you know I don't I don't know
what any of the plans are for section 31
I don't know what any of the plans are
for Starfleet Academy you know I haven't
really engaged that much with lower
decks or or Prodigy
um you know but I think that that it's
we're now at a place we're now at a
point with Star Trek where Nostalgia
needs quite a bit and I think strange
new worlds kind of proves it like Hey
look it's Spock and Kirk and Pike and
Uhura and at some point we're going to
get a young check off you know like you
know they're they're just giving us the
classic Trek in a new coat of paint and
I think it works for lots of reasons but
that is about it not an insignificant
part of it well I know you're the news
man but I can at least share with you
that section 31 was announced as a
Paramount plus exclusive Star Trek movie
with Michelle young just as we all
expected
yeah you know I mean it's a long time
coming I mean I think that was supposed
to be a series at one point then it was
kind of dead at one point and now it's
back because she has an Oscar so it
makes a ton of sense but
um you know again I don't know what that
is I think it's interesting anything
with Michelle yo is always interesting
um but just the the ways that this show
engaged with its past
um and with Canon I thought was really
smart and if you could continue to do
that by all means somebody should do it
yeah it was nice they they brought us
some Nostalgia but they didn't hit us
over the head with it no except for one
big old Starship yeah you know they
brought us some like Easter eggs that
didn't you know actually require like it
weren't plot hinging Easter eggs you
know and if they were like rollerin they
gave you the context for it they
explained why
I mean and and for those of us that are
deep cut fans it's just so beautiful
because her earring was the point of
contention about her her uniform you
know because it's her spiritual belief
and like she Riker admonished her for it
but now it's also the device that she
I'm sorry I'm not spoiling too much yeah
but you know all of which is to say very
much loved
um the final season and the finale of
Star Trek Picard
um I liked the finale season finale of
Mandalorian
um
you know I think we're we're to a
certain degree out of TV to talk about
other than I'll say
um the most recent episode of Ted lasso
is maybe the best episode they've done
in like a season and a half
um I think it's better than anything
this season better than anything from
season two
um I thought it was it was it was just
beautiful and wonderful and did all the
things I want Ted lasso to do it made me
laugh it made me cry it made me give a
a little bit about football
um
but it's just the character stuff you
know in the previous episode too like
the Amsterdam thing was also a pretty
strong episode but like this one was a
just solid out of the park hit
um
yeah I don't know if you want to hear my
opinion on a mark please do because I
feel like I've way overstayed my welcome
um but I thought that it I agree with
you completely it was by far one of the
best episodes ever but the last two
episodes in a way I don't think it was
intentional but in the same way that Ted
Les lasso as a character comes into this
season and was sort of disconnected from
everything going you know like why am I
here I almost kind of felt the same way
about the show I'd been complaining to
my wife actually that the first few
episodes I just I wasn't connecting with
I'm like this isn't the show I'm used to
but then first we got the Amsterdam
episode and we started getting more into
the characters and then with with this
episode as well with more emotional
Hooks and a lot of good comedy as well
it just it really it played hard you can
well you wouldn't ask my wife because
why would you but like I was openly
laughing and then at the end of this
week's episode I was just weeping like a
like a little girl's skin knee oh yeah
like it's so emotional and it's so
I'm not gonna say obvious but like
once you see all of the pieces put
together like of course that's what it
is of course that's why like
and yes just weeping crying like a baby
and then like just tying dicks together
and that's always funny
again a little spoiler-ish but one of
the things that was a great joke uh that
happens then also there's an after
moment with the ever lovable Roy Kent
where he comes up with a bigger plan to
then incorporate tying five or six guys
to the one Central guy and if you watch
the episode later on when there's the
Revelation and a great team building
moment Jamie tart essentially puts
himself in the middle as the dick that
all other dicks are tied to
yeah it's uh it's so good it's so good
and you know and it's if this is the
last season which by all you know
reports it is
um this is a good way to Crest towards
that finale you know kind of remind
everybody why they love the show to
begin with
um you know I don't know if that's
intentional because nobody sets out to
make a Bad episode of TV and I just
think the first couple of episodes just
they lost their way but these past two
have been incredibly energized and I'm
I'm very much
um all about this
this last run of Ted lasso
um and yeah so I think that's that's the
end of review Corner we talk about is
that what you oh I will say two things
maybe one thing two things one thing I
saw uh zisu sisu last night this Finnish
um sort of World War II
um grind Housey movie about this uh this
x Finnish Commando who finds a big hunk
of gold and is trying to like walk it to
the bank where he can exchange it for
money
um and then he gets in uh in conflict
with a bunch of Nazis who are like the
the waning days of World War II who are
like they're gonna they're gonna hang us
or string us up unless we have the money
to to get ourselves out of Germany slash
Europe and so they fixate on this old
guys gold and then it's just him killing
them in interesting ways for like 90
minutes
um
it's uh it's not great
um but it's incredibly enjoyable and in
a hundred percent does not overstay its
welcome it's 90 minutes long and that's
exactly what I want I'm moving like that
you know and coming off of uh off of the
two hour and 45 minute John Wick four
um there was something beautiful about a
90-minute kind of exploitation action
movie
um so if you're in the mood I think it
opens this weekend
um you could do worse then check out
sisu
um and also when you do
if you do
think about that there's probably a
version of this movie that's a silent
film because there's so little dialogue
as it is
um that might even be better for it
um or at least a dialogue free from not
sound because you want all the
explosions and Blood and Guts and stuff
and gunfire and plane crashes and
everything but what dialogue you get you
don't really need and it would be an
interesting exercise to have done this
movie without any
um so that's that
um let's talk a little bit about the
things that dropped at cinemacon I can't
talk in depth about it because I was not
there
um
but let's see there were first looks at
Doom part two uh Martin scorsese's
killer of the flower Moon
um the Fall Guy starring Ryan Gosling
um Wicked part one the adaptation that
Tony winning play a haunting in Venice
the third cute puervo movie
um new trailer for Willy Wonka
um there was news that there's going to
be new Transformers Animated flick
um which will star Chris Hemsworth Brian
Terry Henry Scarlett Johansson Keegan
Michael Key John Hammond Fishburne
um the film apparently will tell the
story of how a young Optimus Prime
played by Chris Hemsworth and not Peter
Cullen but whatever and Megatron Brian
Terry Henry who how they went from being
Brothers in Arms to sworn enemies
um Joe Henson is voicing Elita who I
don't know who it is uh Keegan micro key
will be Bumblebee and the Sentinel Prime
and Fishburn will be Alpha Trion
um that movie's supposed to come out uh
next July July 19th 2024.
and finally there was a screening of The
Flash I think it was still a work in
progress
um but
um by most estimations everybody who saw
it
um you know kind of very much stuck
there were some reservations I think but
nobody would go into explicitly explain
why and thankfully because you know
again this movie is it's it's about a
month away and so don't spoil the thing
we can't see for a month but
um it's encouraging I think
um
you know the other thing I guess to talk
about a little bit and it's hard because
we don't have all of the data
to discuss it with anything
um resembling
um knowledge about the situation but
you know Kev and I have not talked at
all about the Jonathan majors of it all
um you know there's still a lot of
information that we don't know there's
still court dates and you know all kinds
of information that uh that is supposed
to be coming out starting on May 8th I
think there's a court date in New York
um it's a story that has not been told
um and and the details of which are
currently you know a little scatter shot
a little salacious
um and so that's I I don't know what
will happen with both him and his legal
issues nor do I know what will happen
with Jonathan majors and Marvel going
forward
um but it's interesting when you look at
the Ezra Miller of it all and then the
Jonathan majors of it all and then you
have two people who are at the centers
of a giant superhero movie if not phase
of movies if not events
um one of which
um clearly had issues with the law
um clearly had issues of
just woeful and rank and propriety
um
but still got to be in his superhero
because there was a lot of money on the
line I don't think anybody looking in
that situation can say that that's there
is any other reason why
um they hadn't been replaced at the
center of that if it wasn't
uh a in their minds good as far as the
studio goes and B if they had invested
300 some odd million dollars
um and on the other side you have
Jonathan Majors who again we don't know
much of anything about what happened
it's still a lot of he said she said
there's been no courts dates there's
been a discovery there's been no
revelation of much information that
seems solid
um and Jonathan Majors is in Loki season
two but there's a lot of Hope and debate
about whether or not he will still be
Kang going forward
Marvel has people in the past
um nobody quite as
Central to an entire phase as king
um but but they are not they're
definitely not above being like hey
sorry it didn't work out for you bro
um thanks for stopping by for Iron Man
one
and there will be a next time baby
um so I don't know it is just it's
curious to me
what the line is in the sand
that Studios that production companies
that audiences will accept
um from the people who star in their
superhero movies what how where's
the difference between one versus the
other
um what kind of things are we willing to
overlook
and and I have an answer to that I you
know I just don't but it's
it is curious to me
um that this is where we are in uh in in
this particular genre in this Arena
so
apparently the flash is good we'll see
you know I'll go see it because I'm
gonna go see it but
um it's uh it's
curiouser and curiouser as the cat says
they will hey sorry I thought my wife
Mike wasn't on I was just gonna say I
I'm all for at least for a brief amount
of time separating the the artist from
the art if you will uh but I will say
that that uh there's one person there
are three people I trust in this world
when it comes to advice on things Kevin
you and I know that straw had goofy uh
Juju was also at cinemacon and I saw him
report uh he wouldn't say much but he
did say that it was good so that's all I
need to hear and I think it's probably
the first DC EU movie that I'm actually
caring about
yeah you know and and it it I'm I've
been sold by the trailers you know and
again weaponized Nostalgia like if
you're gonna give me Michael Keaton back
who wants to get nuts
um as Batman then then
you know you have my attention
um and so that's the the bit of it that
I'm curious about if the rest of it
holds as a movie
you know then all the better you know if
they did the work of like listen we know
we're going to get a certain amount of
attention because we got Keaton back you
know we know we're gonna get a certain
amount of attention because we got
Affleck back
um
but if the movie Underneath It All works
then then I'm then you have like
curiosity and my attention and my money
um but yeah I I I haven't heard anybody
say it was awful I haven't heard anybody
just like shoot it's open mouth yet
um I just heard that you know some
people say it's good people say it has
some issues people say they enjoyed it
um but we'll find out and I think it's
June
um mid-june so fingers crossed fingers
crossed send my con seems like a ton of
fun one of these days I'll get out there
I know Kevin had been planning to but
life had other plans for him so
um
but uh but that's it that's all that's
all we have to report really
um did you want to handle any questions
there have been a few sure let's do some
q a I don't want to push it into
anything uh one person asked a good
question that I thought and relevant
some of the topics that we've talked
about tonight uh of course their name
has as long I think it might have been
Mark B and his question is based on
everything we've seen what show is it
you would be interested in doing in the
Star Trek universe
um I suppose I can answer this question
because then we'll never ask me to do a
show in the Star Trek universe
um my my Representatives I'm sure will
say Never Say Never there's always a
chance but I think that every story
we've ever had in Star Trek has been
from the federation's perspective
it has all been one version of the
events that we've seen
um
and even though we've delved into
certain planets and cultures and species
and beings and worlds and and all that
stuff
the stories have been told from their
perspective it's always been told from
the federation's point of view or from a
federation uh Starfleet
officer
um interacting with that culture
um but I think I'd want to see a Klingon
show
um and whether it's a wharf show whether
it's a you know Klingon history show
whether it's Game of Thrones but on the
Klingon Homeworld which seems like it's
a perfectly right place for
chaos and backstabbing and politics and
War and you know space dominance and all
that stuff like I I think there's just a
lot of juice there that has never been
squeezed
um
uh even though Klingons have been you
know part of Star Trek since the jump
but we've never we've never gone under
the hood I mean next gen went as deep as
anybody ever did
um and Deep Space Nine got us into you
know wharf's journey and you know the
Legends and the Lords of you know kales
and and core and all that stuff but
I think just a Klingon show and then
seeing the Federation from a different
point of view seeing Starfleet from a
different point of view seeing you know
what it means to to come to conflict
with somebody who claims to have the
best intentions
um but maybe doesn't
um you know or at least from their
perspective does it
um I just think it'd be interesting I
just think it'd be interesting and I
could use some more interesting in my
Star Trek other than like more dudes in
red and gold shirts sitting behind the
bridge of a Starship that's lit like an
Apple store you know just going off in
space faring and doing the right thing
all the time now that you say that I'll
tell you mark B's example and that's
what he would love to do a hairy mud
show which could angle right into other
parts
of the Federation or the Starfleet or
that universe yeah for sure I think
that's it's a big Galaxy and we've seen
very little of it uh wild Samurai has a
question and he asks uh because these
topics have come up and have led to
great discussion well actually I don't
know his motivation I don't know why I'm
narrating what video games are if any
are you playing right now
um I am currently playing the uh The
Horizon forbidden West expansion uh the
DLC burning Shores
um and I'm always surprised
at
because listen you've played video games
you've all played video games right
we're on this yeah you're watching me
talk about nerd we're all of this
age and era
there are
what eight
a 12 buttons
two triggers and two joysticks on every
controller that's an insane amount of
information to map to your brain and
grab any context clues for what each one
of those buttons do which is why like
you'll never get my mom playing a video
game because she has no idea what to do
with 20 buttons and two joysticks and
how to make that work
um so it's always amazing to me that I
could not play a game for like a year
and then pick up an expansion or dive
back into that game and it takes about
90 seconds before I remember what all
the buttons do without looking them up
without like checking the the pause
screen without going into options or
anything it's just it all kind of clicks
back into my mind and I find that
fascinating
um because it's a thoroughly unuseful
trait or skill in any other regard
except for playing video games
um
but that right now is the one that I'm
sort of into
um I'm I'm unclear if I'm gonna play
um Jedi Survivor I just didn't like
that last Jedi game
um
yeah
to say it was the save mechanics of it
like I play too much and then die and
then get cycled back too far and it just
got frustrating like why am I playing a
game that feels like it was you know the
same mechanics were invented in 1998.
um as opposed to which is a constant you
know where I am you know where I got
just bring me back here that's cool
right yeah
um
so yeah I don't know what else is next I
don't know what else is next
um I I tend to to then decide I want to
replay a game that I played before and
loved
um so I'm not sure if it'll be like
third replay of Red Dead Redemption 2 or
I'm playing Mass Effect in a long time
but I love that game
um
or is there another like go through of
Last of Us Parts one and or two
um I do tend to to cycle back like your
favorite books that like I know some
people read Lord of the Rings once a
year
um that's a lot of Lord of the Rings to
read you know every 12 months but some
people do you know I think I'm that way
with games a little bit but like the
great ones I'll replay over and over
again I could definitely understand that
and I guess I every single year for some
reason I reread the unabridged version
of Stephen King's The Stand
yeah I mean people have books that they
love and they return to them because
they love those stories and they love
being in those worlds and and games do
that to me as well for me you know like
I'm just not a multiplayer person I
figured that out about five years ago
but like so yeah I've got Modern Warfare
too but I'm never gonna just wander in
and just start shooting random people
and get tea bagged by 12 year olds who
are way better at it than I am I think
that doesn't seem fun
I understand completely
uh first I just want to share with you
Tim Salman says not a question but I
just want to say I love black man beyond
nothing against Kevin but it's wonderful
to hear Mark have complete well okay let
me just stop it there
um
but let me tell you all these things let
me man that's one of those things where
you really should have redhead on the
prompter Ron Burgundy anyone uh and the
last question then so that way we can
let Mark get back to his evening
um which I don't know how to pronounce
this person's name I'm just gonna think
it says Wyatt butts
um and teen off of my comment about a
book uh what Stephen King's Story would
you like to make into a film uh what
would it be and why
um my
it's funny my Stephen King I think
everybody has their Stephen King Journey
right they have their first books they
discovered they have the kind of books
that they like you know I think the the
stand is early on for lots of people
Dark Tower is The Shining Carrie Cujo
the early books misery if they saw the
movie and then went back to the to that
book and then
Central spread out
um
I think my first Stephen King book was
eyes of the Dragon
um because I think I was a huge Hobbit
fan and I had never read any Stephen
King but it's like oh wait this is also
has dragons and fantasy that's cool let
me try this and that was my way in but I
have I have always for as long as I can
remember as a reader my favorite Stephen
King is the Running Man uh the Richard
Bachmann from the Bachmann books running
man
um and since I started writing as an
amateur not even professional it was 10
years before anybody would pay me to
write anything in a screenplay format
um but I wanted to adapt that
um first is a movie and then more
recently I wanted to do as a mini series
because I do think that
you know the Schwarzenegger movie
notwithstanding like it is what it is
and as as ever was thus
but as a story
um as a book as a novella I guess you
have to call it
has a lot to say about the current
temper of the world that we're in has a
lot to say about class it has a lot to
say about race it has a lot to say about
entertainment and and the the praying of
the entertainment conglomerates on the
uh the random viewer the random citizen
you know the power of broadcast to unite
a people
um and
and Desperation like what happens when
you're on the bottom of the American
caste system which very much exists
um
when somebody gives you an opportunity
is it genuine or is there some nefarious
purpose
um behind it and so and it's super
exciting like there's lots of like you
know cool action stuff there's lots of
great personal stuff
um the ending is Bleak as
um but I love it for that and I think
you could probably do that and do now
um in a way you couldn't have done in
the past you know
15 years 20 years
um but yeah that's the one that I do
um it it pains me to to to have to stare
down the battle of the fact that Edgar
Wright uh had been attached to direct
the feature version of that for
Paramount I don't know where that is if
it's still happening
I mean I like Edgar's work so I hope it
does I'd like to see that version of it
but I'd also like to tell my version of
it
um and so until uh until Edgar's uh
implodes I'll just have to to be content
to live and watch from the sidelines
um waiting for somebody to put me in
for the NFL draft brought to you by
manscaped see I could do that too I
thought you weren't gonna get that but I
I can bring things around
sort of dovetailer ads back into the
content
um yeah so so that's the one that's the
one running man
um
I don't want to think about the movie
that's already existing as much as I
want to think about the version that's
on the page and in my head
that's the one Mr butts
Miss it's Mr butts to you
it
one last question from the guy who just
won't get off camera with you uh as a
writer are there some things that that
when you're between projects but to
maybe keep the old muscle going or just
from Passion do you ever actually write
like a spec script for some of these
projects that you would want to do
um I don't
and that's not to say that somebody else
shouldn't because the first thing that I
ever wrote by myself was a spec
adaptation of the running man like I did
it just to see if I could do it you know
didn't have the rights to it nobody was
paying me to do it like I just loved the
book and thought it could work and so I
did it as sort of an exercise
um
you know the older I would get and the
the more I realized that
um trying to make the things that I
write
able to work for me in as many ways as
possible
um writing an adaptation you know it
becomes fan fiction right like sure you
can write a Batman Pro story you can't
really do anything with it because you
don't own Batman and the odds of getting
it to DC or Warner Brothers and then
publishing it as a novel or it's a short
story whatever or slim to none and so
you're just doing it for fun which go
for it
um but I try to to write things that
have the maximum potential of doing more
so I'd rather write a new thing that I
can either use as a sample to get work
that I can sell as as a piece of
material that can then still also get me
work but
there's nothing I can do with that
script I wrote Of The Running Man
because again don't own it somebody
could sell the rights right from under
me which they did
um and so I think that it's just it's a
poor use of time
um and so in between the stuff that I'm
you know actively engaged on and getting
paid to write I'll write stuff for
myself
um you know I'll work on on ideas that
that you know I jotted down in a
notebook or it flushed out whatever and
put more meat on the bones or
you know but it's it's rare that I that
I go back to a thing that I've loved and
say like I'm just gonna write
that that'd be fun wouldn't it be fun
um because it does feel a bit like you
know there's no sex in that champagne
room you know you are never gonna have
the time you think you're gonna have
writing the thing that doesn't belong to
you
um
uh so yeah that would be my one bit of
advice you know if you're if you want to
write a superhero story don't write a
Superman story because there's not very
much you can do with that but invent a
character like Superman sure like file
the serial numbers off
um that has worked for lots of people
you know uh I'm pretty sure that
Twilight was supposed to be you know 50
Shades of Gray uh fanfic or vice versa I
don't remember exactly how the the
entomology of those two worked out but
one of them was supposed to be then the
other thing
and they're like you know what it
what if it's bondage instead of vampires
I think it was the gray after the
sparkly
thank you guys sparkled or vampire
um
and so like yeah if if that's what you
want to write about it you want to write
about you know that kind of power and
balance between the Sexes and if you
want to write about you know sexy time
sexy time and having to leave your
family to go off with this dude who
seems a little bit kinky then like do it
but don't make it 50 shades make it
whatever 20 blinds and you're all set
fair enough
appreciate that Insight
because I think I think if my memory
serves me one of one of my uh Die Hard
with the Vengeance I believe could be
wrong was originally written as a Lethal
Weapon movie and then got repurposed but
you know I remember I think what I it
wouldn't surprise me I know that there
was a spec screenplay called Simon Says
that fox had bought and then they they
hammered that then into Die Hard with a
Vengeance
um but it also wouldn't surprise me that
there was another script out there that
they just kind of like we like this part
of this maybe like that part of that and
put John McLean in it and then it's all
good to go
um that does happen sometimes but um
but yeah
yeah man awesome well that's all I got
to say about that I'll go away so you
can say goodbye to everybody you know
that's all I have to say about that and
I think that's all I have to say about
this episode of black man beyond
um
uh the next black man beyond episode
will be in uh I think next weekend I'm
recording it at the northern fan con and
Prince George
um BC uh I'll be there the I think it's
the fifth sixth and the seventh maybe or
fourth fifth and sixth I don't know how
dates work
um but I'll be up there I will be
interviewing um Emily swallow who played
the armorer on the Mandalorian and uh
and I'll see if she takes issue with any
of my criticisms
um I hope not because none of them are
personal they never are
um so I'll be up there in another Penny
con for a couple days if you happen to
live in that particular part of Canada
uh come say hi I always have a good time
up there
um and and if you are there coming to me
hello
um we are going to be planning
episode 400 of fat man beyond hopefully
uh it'll be in the next two or three
weeks depending on kev's schedule
depending on when we get tickets up and
depending if you guys decide you want to
buy you come hang out at the Cantina and
celebrate 400 episodes of the
daffy's podcast ever
um I feel like it's gonna be a good time
but uh you'll have to be there to find
out or on the internet where we're
streaming at the same time I mean what
are we kidding
um but I think that's all I have to
report you guys I think uh I think
that's all that's happening in the world
to talk about tonight
um thank you so much for spending some
time with me on this Thursday evening
slash early afternoon slash middle of
the night if you're in the UK
um not sure when we'll be back but I
hope it's soon uh until that time
um I have been Mark Bernard and this has
been black man beyond uh tune in next
time same black Time same black Channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com Kevin Smith
just kisses for the good of all Cree May
the force be with you
um I can't that hand do it right I don't
know anyway live long and prosper you
guys
Pizza
this greetings everybody and welcome to
the AKA ask if anything every Saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with Jay and
Silent Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]